you saw they changed the definition of a
heartbeat they changed the definition of
heartbeat and you know why they did they
did because of to back Stacey Abrams
they no they changed it before she said
that oh really Planned Parenthood
changed the definition of of heartbeat
oh they said that it's not a heartbeat
it's cardiac activity at six weeks oh
well they were saying that in 2017 as
well yeah yeah and the reason they did
this is because the heartbeat bills that
are being passed right so yeah they did
that in 2017 in the Atlantic and then in
2021 definition well they started
talking about what cardiac activity
actually means and then Parenthood did
blogs about it in 2021. they pass a law
that says once a heartbeat is detected
you can't get an abortion the media
comes out and says not heartbeat well
that's you know that's what it's been
with so many things you know I feel like
we should have a running glossary of
words that have been changed to suit the
Biden Administration from heartbeat to
recession uh to vaccine efficacy you
know like all of these various things